three two one boom and we're live what's
happening Joe what's up Mike Tom Segura
now that man minutes yeah man by to say
hi I can't believe you've never had a
cup of coffee
never you want something no that might
be that might be the most outrageous
thing about is that you've never had
coffee your whole life I've never had
coffee No
did you just tea no coffee no one ever
offered you a cup of coffee you never
went to Starbucks no fatir from donut
Wow
what about like adults when you are
miles and um that wasn't me getting
rehabbed it was a little Starbucks
because the means right outside of
Starbucks you always hang on a Starbucks
right but never for coffee you didn't
want to try it
never hmm that is that how about like
like girlfriends wives like none of them
ever like drank coffee at home I'm sure
they have I never really my wife drinks
it and you just nothing no nothing no no
well I'm so drugged that did you think
coffee would be nothing yeah yeah like
it doesn't make any sense
when when did you first try any drugs
kid you're kidding what kind of [ __ ]
smoking and drinking right then as I got
older I tried acid how old were you mean
first tried actually 11 Wow really young
Jesus man
wow that's really young Wow
but when you were the champ when you
were in your prime like when you
wouldn't like when you beat Trevor
Berbick were you doing anything back
then its drinking a lot drinking a lot
really yeah that's amazing
will you go clean for camp or like if it
can't you just for camping if it can
yeah but outside like once fights over
yeah yeah yeah
you were the first guy that I ever use
as an example of to break that old myth
that you can't have sex before fights
and I was like well that's out the
window for sure cuz you you talk about
it all the time you'd blow yeah yeah
pretty much yeah
your logic made sense to you like I
don't want to think about it I don't
want to be thinking about sex I'll just
get it out of the way
yeah and it's over what do you have to
do
have a feel for the next time six weeks
and yes going to fight do you think that
was a myth that it made you weak yeah I
think it's a myth yeah doesn't seem to
make sense it seems odd yeah
and then they like whenever they buy you
more so than you know disintegrate you
yeah I would think they said that the
Olympic you know where the athletes stay
is just like [ __ ] fest just panting so
yeah also probably you want to alleviate
some anxiety anxiety freaking out you're
at the Olympics you know 18 years old
and everyone's in amazing shape stressed
out yeah when you were when you were
first coming up and when you were first
we like when you were kid dynamite on
Sports Illustrated I'll never forget
that man that was a that your era from
like you know the the eighties the late
80s that era like it was a big part of
my youth you know like you being cam and
you being the chant was like it was a
change of things because when Larry
Holmes was the champ as a boxing fan
I loved Larry Holmes like there's that
cover you were 19 years old yeah it's
nuts
when Larry Holmes is a champ as a boxing
fan why you still got that stuff man
you just still get those yeah Sports
Illustrated it's the Internet you can
find it on you know that's how Jamie got
it I had that Sports Illustrated but
when Larry Holmes was a champ as a
boxing fan I appreciated him I knew he
was a great fighter I you know we would
get together with friends and watch like
the the Michael Spinks fight with Larry
Holmes yeah when Spinks beat him for the
title it was a big deal but it wasn't a
big deal
culturally yeah people didn't care as
much but then you came around and when
you came around all of a sudden
everybody's watching heavyweight boxing
if heavyweight boxing wasn't it wasn't
boring again it was the the most crazy
exciting thing in sports when your
fights would go on it would be about
should I pay for this cuz how long is
this gonna last my dad never had it's
really weird people tell me about the
time they all chipped in yeah
I know think about it like that you know
sometimes when it comes from our
realization of the situation I forget
that I'm that guy forget that I train
that hard and I became a fighter and
stuff yeah that's what I was going to
ask you
like deep does it seem like a dream yeah
pretty much like a blur because I
couldn't imagine what it would be like
to be 19 years old 20 years old that
[ __ ] famous it was a trip who can
handle that is then can anybody handle
that no it was a trip but it was just
what custom model you know that was his
blueprint it makes me write teenage
superstar did he give you advice on how
to handle pressure and fame and Oh
depression everything but you know if
there's really no ingredients on how to
handle thing you know I mean we have to
see what what Department of Fame is your
problem and we have to work on that
issue from there but you know no one's
know how to conduct themselves under
that kind of pressure no doctor it's at
the level of Fame - yes like there's so
many you realize there's so many levels
of Fame and then Mike's is still just
extraordinary where like people people
walk away from their job like in an
airport they're supposed to be at the
cash register and they run out you know
they leave their job to go say hi that's
not you know most of the time you like
oh that's who that person is it's a
totally different thing oh where does
that that's pretty weird [ __ ] away from
email creep might come in pick up it
your mother take a picture my kid take a
picture here take a picture I love you
Justin I'm like whoa dude cool out but
now you know anything this is just what
it is it is stop it
yeah I've seen you at the UFC before
you're very calm around people when
people grabbing at you want to take
pictures you just just relax
the UFC is all I think of everybody's
nut yeah yeah it's a it's it's
definitely a wild environment
what do you think of beeps gonna do now
but I think who could be yeah well he
does whatever the [ __ ] he wants to do
that's what I think I think that guy's
probably the best lightweight of all
time he's a monster
incredible he I think he's probably
gonna have some fights at 170 pounds
eventually if I'd imagine at 155 there's
you know there's good fights for him
Tony Ferguson it's a great fight for him
I'm really interested in seeing that I'm
really interested in seeing him going up
I'm really interested to see him fight
at 170 pounds look they from the fight
well first of all tyron woodley who's
the champ at 170 that would be an insane
fight George st. Pierre if he decided to
come back and make a big super fight
that would be an insane fight I think
170 has a lot of opportunities for him
but I think 155 does too they just have
to figure out who's gonna fight him he's
an international superstar now you know
could be especially the way he smashed
Conor Conor such a superstar already
that the way khabib won and did it so
dominant I think he's I think he's
through the roof now I think when people
when he comes back and people see the
pay-per-view numbers of his fights are
gonna realize how huge this guy is
because he's so interesting he's very
humble very very he's very polite very
well-spoken
a very religious guy lives with his
family lives with his parents lives of
his parents his family I believe yeah
hope I'm not speaking out of school I
believe that's true and obviously it
doesn't have to for money he's rich as
[ __ ] now yeah but he's just a monster
the best best grappler I've ever seen
inside the hundred fifty five pound
division he just smashes people anything
about John Jones though what in what way
and his skill he's phenomenal incredible
the best ever
using distance he knows distance better
than anybody he's a master at knowing
when he can hit you and you can hit miss
watching him fight you know he's back
you just won just won the title again
just find out Andy Gustafson yeah yeah a
couple weeks ago yeah vacant title it
was Daniel Cormier relinquished his
title and it was like it's weird right
a Cormier is the champ because Jon Jones
tested positive for something so they
stripped him and then Cormier became the
champ it's a you know I think they'll
probably fight again whether they fight
again at heavy way
like having really yeah I think Cormier
and John Johnson for me wants to once
keep going he says he wants to retire
soon he's 40
you know yeah I feel looks good he looks
great especially at heavyweight and
heavyweight he's he doesn't have to cut
weight he's got so much strength and -
so agile he's such an unbelievable
wrestler - I mean his wrestling skill
his skill level and understanding of
wrestling is so high so above mostly
anybody find out find a gym John Jones
he dominates yeah yeah that's how good
John is John's dad good he's doctor I
mean it just sucks that he's had so many
controversies in his life but I'm hoping
he puts all that [ __ ] behind him have
you ever spoken with him about that
never Bundys personal life anything when
we met before and talked well you're a
guy who's gone I mean when you went
through legal problems yourself you you
overcame you came out of it on the other
hand I think would think a guy like him
could benefit a lot from so it's just so
difficult and so unfortunately they have
to go do something yeah you know do you
think so yes you know sometimes people
they don't survive situations like that
cuz they're so wild and they're having a
good time too much in the party and head
of the champ you have to have to come to
an end
that's tough if you don't bring it to an
end bring come to his own end it might
not like that yeah so you think Ferg I
like him maybe getting in trouble was a
good thing if only if you learn from
experiences like that yeah you know I
thought I was just a wild guy I was
really a wild guys I look at myself now
and I say to myself when I spent those
trips in those psych wards and so what
was that all about
what what's wrong with me back then you
know yeah really disturbed back then but
you're somebody who got to the point
where you got like it's really
fascinating because I know you know
you're a public figure so we you know
I've been able to watch you my whole
life
you went through all that stuff and then
you got to this point where you're a
very self-reflective and you look at you
are able to comment on it I don't think
most I mean most people regardless of
whether they're famous or not just still
don't get to that point where they're
able to look back and examine who they
were and doing wild [ __ ] and
ruthless honesty yeah that's okay
reflecting yourself to discover who you
really are
yeah when you're twenty years old and
all of a sudden you're the heavyweight
champion the world in just a few years
ago you were poor and now all the sudden
you're the king of the world that's
really crazy
you know really I was unable to handle
it I wouldn't expect that that was a
really [ __ ] puncher idea that Charlie
Murphy told us a story and it's animated
it's on YouTube now of you and him
coming over your house in a limousine
and you Ella it was a lion or a tiger
tiger theme of the line for the tiger
dude it is one of the craziest [ __ ]
stories I always when surfer people who
don't know I got to hang out with you at
one of my shows one time and it was a
great I had the best time talking about
everything what made you think you could
get a tiger so I'm in prison at the time
so I'm in prison I'm talking to my car
dealer at the time and he has a he has
some cars to belong to a friend of Mines
esposa friend of ours and he's
discussing if he doesn't pay for these
cars imma sell these cars to someone and
get some horses horses lions tigers I'll
see you do can you give me some tigers
yeah man how cool that baby because I
had a bunch of friends because man that
man you be in the Aston Martin or
Ferrari have a tiger right next to you
that would be cool right yeah give me
some consonant then when I came home I
had those Cubs right there waiting for
me so you raised them as Cubs yeah
that's that's how you were cuz I would
see footage of you like [ __ ] smacking
them around and jumping on one of your
Tigers and I was like holy [ __ ] and I
had wasn't their bag that their mother
the mother there
baby now it never gets this is a crazy
picture you and your underwear with a
tiger on a chain that is that is one of
the as dance right there that's you a
peak crazy
yeah insane yeah going through my mind
made me think about my friend said Mike
you can get some awesome animals I'm
gonna give him hot for everybody does it
though
those are things about what's his face
from narcos Oh Pablo asked you got like
a [ __ ] zoo yeah they all do it don't
you get like that rich you're like just
get some Adam that's right Jack Noah
that's right Michael Jackson yeah the
zoo and his back that's true yeah that
weird [ __ ] like weird birds yeah I don't
think it may be out of monkey or
something he did have weird okay nothing
Dane hung up there before at the Playboy
Mansion this is at the end of his career
if I can't well the thing years ago
something that was pretty awesome yeah
that guy man what a life he lived you
yeah pajamas they're sucking his balls
and he's 80 and [ __ ] no deep into his
90s yeah that's yeah he'd be really
here's the thing that dude lived the
lifestyle he was talking about you know
a lot of people talk [ __ ] yeah you don't
really do that
he was really dark
after getting dark too much yeah wait
one other thing I got it cuz I got it
run I wanted that going man I gotta go I
gotta go meet the wife man oh yeah
they'll do it I read one time cuz
alright so for people that know I met
Mike on a flight and it was a surreal
experience you know like from from being
a kid and thinking like this is Superman
that's what I thought as a kid I just
you know I mean like those well you see
it as a kid - I think it's different
like you're just like
that is so nuts like these 11 second
knock out you know is so bizarre
periodically even to this day people
come up to me and talk about the
experience that they feel how many
talked about meeting me through that
true story is that true yeah mostly
stories you know and it was a it was a
surreal experience and you know we spoke
on the plane and and then like well I
thought we were done talking you know
how I face forward and then he came back
and like tapped me on the shoulder I was
like oh [ __ ] like Mike's talking to me
I'm down here like seat belt seat belt
it in but then we land and and he was
like oh where's your show and and and I
go oh here it's here I gave him the
number never expect to hear hits me up
the next day and he's like we're coming
to your show and I was like oh my god
and I really did say like I'm amazed
that you're coming and he said it's all
love and I just said I love you what to
say I I remember I called the the
Pittsburgh improv manager and I go hey
man I just go you're not gonna believe
this but
Tyson's coming to the fight tonight he
goes Mike Tyson I go no [ __ ] Tyson
chicken yeah Mike Tyson's coming tonight
he's like I'll corridor off a whole
thing and you know and I didn't know he
was at the show because it the show had
already started I didn't see him arrive
and we go back to the green after I did
the show I walk up offstage and he grabs
me and he goes let's go to the green
room so he took me to my greenroom right
like he was like and I was like [ __ ]
yeah and we hung out in that green room
over an hour and just shooting the [ __ ]
and talking and when I forgot like if
the time had passed I opened the door
the entire staff entire staff is lined
up at the door to meet him like that's
the effect that he has on the group you
know like they're waiting in a line for
an hour outside the greenroom
and I you know we talked about boxing
about life it was it was fascinating one
of the things I really appreciated about
you as a fighter was like that you
really knew that you were putting on a
show so that that's something that I
feel like I miss
you know there's there's no one that put
on the show the way you did like you
knew the people bought tickets and and
paid for the pay-per-view and then it
you know it's still like one of my great
memories man it was a thrill to meet you
so I just wanted to stop by and say
sounds like you wrap it girl I do
oh by the way did you buy seven
Bentley's that were the same color
no but I put around seven Bentley's
before damn they're Rolls Royces I
wanted ask you did give away one when
you crashed it right yeah I was married
at the time the Robin Givens and we were
in some fast food chain we order food
and she went my pocket I guess to get
some money I'm about to pay for and
she's had some fun condoms came out and
she was mad so she got in the car and
then blowww she crashed the car into
another car that was just parked it blew
and she hit somebody and she hurt their
arm and then the cops came and so the
cops came to cut floor say hey what
happened here right and I was afraid of
they were gonna arrest me I said well
nothing happened officer nothing then
the guy was and it was a guy was broken
on my face you know sir
why don't you just take the car you know
you deserve because you've been doing a
lot cuz I didn't want to get arrested
they have rises in all my life to get in
trouble
just take it you know maybe with nuns
around 230 at the time someone just take
it if you okay the guys hey don't tell
me that and then once he said that
forgot oh I got him nothing man take him
into this man she deserves this take it
and they took but before that the guys
some guy almost broke in and he's I gave
him my money and I take the money and
then he came back to the police my army
but a couple now you get away from I'm
not gonna tell you to get away from me
no more cuz he didn't want to mess this
deal up with this car cuz the guy that's
a little cocky don't [ __ ] come near
me again the guy is back off and I say
go ahead me I feel it but they made him
give away the car right there
Lily cuz I went back to my office I keep
my [ __ ] car back fired
get that bastard title my Indian giver
with my car man Oh No
Mike Tyson calls you up just give me my
[ __ ] comic [ __ ] yeah it's outside man
I got a killer damn it you guys know I
embarked on the marijuana but yes yes
this is this by the way Thank You Man
for accepting my pleasure
yeah that's a cool ass box man yeah -
Rance is gonna be opening a pretty
shortly you guys have to I saw that
wheel and this is a big deal this place
is gigantic
what's a state it's it's in California
cool yeah they're setting up like a
resort
really yeah gonna be the best facility
in the world man's gonna be on if we're
not gonna fake along Lake Wow yeah you
could go it's like he knows gonna be
camping glamping like glamping glamorous
camping glamorous camping us may have
some tigers of [ __ ] for some wild
ability my pinkie was discussing that -
where are those times I had him for like
14 years so I had to get rid of what do
you do when you want to get rid of a
tire I thank you weary
oh I got a run I love you cannabis dude
there it is
yeah Congrats on that man that looks
dope awesome them folks at about this is
so awesome yeah you you seem to be
really enjoying this like when you're
talking to your partner's out there
you're you're having a good time with
this oh man I never thought that and the
million years I'd be able to do this and
legalize yeah
when did you start like regularly
smoking weed I'm since I was like 10 you
though
the whole time we were fighting you were
regular smoking week well you know when
your kid your mother gives you liquor
and marijuana for you make you think
that you're gonna go to sleep or
something yeah really yeah that never
happened in my house no yeah damn that's
that's harsh
liquor and marijuana see if you go to
sleep yeah it didn't work I don't think
so
do you uh what what benefits you get out
of marijuana like what does it do for
you hey man uh if I didn't have a bad
day
yeah I'm really moody guy without it and
it's just um he smooths me out still
they think I'm a whole different person
yeah on top of my game
I'm ballin yeah I feel the same way
sometimes it makes me nicer yeah yeah
calms me down
do you like Who I am I smoke you know I
mean when I'm when I weed I don't think
I'm like Who I am sometimes that's just
the real thing yeah yeah I don't like
that guy want to get away from that guy
well you know I was talking to Michael
Irvin once he was explaining to me that
when children grow up in high stress
environments that their genes are wired
to have a propensity towards violence
that they're normal if it's normal if
it's around them all the time when
they're when they're growing up and when
they're in the womb yeah I agree
when their mothers under extreme stress
if they live in a bad neighborhood the
and it's it's hard for some people like
yourself that did grow up in an
environment like that to ever reach
where you're at right now just a place
of peace and if you can do that through
marijuana or whatever it is yoga
meditation whatever it whatever you do
to get there like we should be happy
that you can get there that's what we
don't listen I'm so grateful that um I
embarked on this you know I've never
been a person to this it's magnitude
that this kind of relaxation is enjoying
my time with you I was very up tighter
than anything I was very uncomfortable
with myself did you feel any better
after you worked out when you were young
like that absolutely my works out um you
know what um the best thing that
happened to me that retired from boxing
is with me working out and meeting I was
so intense with this my whole my whole
objective was hurting people and
wouldn't be the best of my ego took over
and I'm like icing on the best living
all this [ __ ]
and the other with my partner Rob
Hickman I happen to embark on this come
across this thing called the toad and he
familiar with the toad
yeah well you're talking about his five
methoxy powerful that fit right there
yeah yeah and I came across that and um
guys smoke this on I don't know this
medicine drug whatever you want to call
it and I've never been the same I look
at life differently look at people
differently and the experiment that
can't even express really it's almost
like dying and being real reborn yeah I
had the exact same experience that's
what it felt like to me to like you stop
existing the five meth oxys uh there's
two tell me what's the deal with the
five methoxy is produced by your brain
but what it is is it's DMT with an
oxygen molecule attached to it there's a
regular DMT is N and dimethyltryptamine
and then five methoxy dimethyltryptamine
is DMT with like a very there's a very
subtle change to the molecule and that
subtle change for some reason takes away
the visuals you've done regular DMT too
right yes
regular DMT is rich with visuals very
strained bright colorful impossible to
describe visuals if and yes if
inconceivable inconceivable is best way
but I tried to explain it to some people
my wife and I it's just I don't have the
words to explain it that's exactly what
I always say I've done a terrible job
explaining it to everybody every time
I've tried it just doesn't work but all
those things they give you perspectives
almost like you're dying you have you
you're submissive you're humble you know
you're vulnerable but you're invincible
still in all you know this isn't that
weird feeling but you feel like you're
part of the universe when you're
separate from your ego you realize this
whole thing you're a part of this whole
thing and this whole things and
stoppable it's just it's a gigantic huge
all-encompassing almost like a living
thing I know John this is what I also
realized to have to go into the
experience you realize how insignificant
you are sometimes without the ego yeah
you know yeah that's why you're not
really much that you really thought you
were yeah you are and you aren't
obviously you are in everyday life I
mean you go places you have a dramatic
effect on people you mean a lot you mean
a lot to those people that you run into
you mean a lots of the people that you
love and that love you but we all do and
when the no one's standing no it's all
it's all relative no one no one is
irreplaceable but everyone is special to
someone or something and at least to
themselves but we're all the same we're
all part of this weird crazy gigantic
organism that's the human race you know
so odd that you say that my mentor
custom Otto his objective was to think
of nothing you're nothing nothing's
nothing but the objective the job and
then I was a psychological warfare
you know nothing matters you're nothing
nothing my only thing a matter that's
objective and getting to accomplishing
that objective by going to these methods
of boxing do you ever stop and think
about how fortunate was you ran into
that guy till this day I really don't
understand that though how did this
happen so many people listen by the time
I was born he was 66 years old by the
time I was born yeah crazy so many
people could you know can't even explain
it it's a magnificent individual he was
an amazing guy an amazing part of boxing
and with a unprecedented grasp of the
mindset required for combat sports that
was the thing that always really stood
out about him like he was a guy that was
so he was so well-versed in the mindset
I would listen to his his speeches that
he would talk when he would talk about
you and he we talk about boxing we
talked about fear and about fear can be
a calf ire can cook your food or it can
burn your house down and you have to you
have to control it and when he would
describe it like it would be so
enlightening he was such a man of wisdom
that when he would describe things they
would sink in they would they would they
would somebody could say the same thing
but they were with him he had so much
life he wasn't any happy the
psychiatrist he was the doctor the
father the mother you know he was just
all around that individual
yeah and with an amazing knowledge of
boxing and forgot like you it was almost
like it was ordained and that's what
always failed with nem for me to meet
this guy cuz I had no way in a million
years everybody sees no way you're gonna
be Jimi too small yeah sure no way this
guys are too big for you the greatest
fight ever layer this and there's only
famous achieve what he was saying and
things he was saying was so gigantic in
my eyes yeah yeah I mean when it all
happened and it turned out that he was
true and you have to absorb all this
when you're 20 years old you know it's I
would say this about justin bieber and i
don't think justin bieber nearly had to
deal with what you had to deal with your
your experience was so much crazier
because you were not just an incredibly
famous guy you were the baddest man on
the planet so there was like an aura to
you everywhere you went people wanted to
see you you know 50-year old men don't
give a [ __ ] about justin bieber you know
no disrespect he's a great guy a great
singer but it's not he's like young
girls for young girls that guy's
unbelievably famous but he's he's been
famous since he was a little kid like
when people hear amazing when people
hear about him going and saying like of
course he's going insane you have no
idea what it would be like to be him and
to be 17 years old and girls literally
trying to break into his house to throw
a [ __ ] at him
they're coming down chimneys they're
flying in on parachutes doing anything
they can they just want to be around him
and you want him to be normal no one can
handle that what kind of music you
listening to I listen to everything that
they do I listen to a bit I was in a lot
of classic rock for whatever reason but
I've been listening a lot of Kanye West
over the last few weeks he talking about
Kanye yeah well he's talking about a lot
of crazy [ __ ] he's tired he actually
talked about DMT in one of his recent
song yeah you think he did that before I
think he did oh man
why no he's friends with Kid Cudi mm-hmm
Kid Cudi's been in here and Kid Cudi's
had some psychedelic experiences yeah
once you go to is your thumb you don't
want to do nothing else again
well it puts it all in the perspective
lets you see that uh as much as this
thing seems to be important this is all
temporary and you're a part of forever
and it also allows you to become
comfortable with death yeah yeah you
know who said that Larry Hagman remember
that guy Dallas yeah
from jr. he did an interview with CNN
and I Dream of Jeannie as well yeah
that's right he sprung it on him on CNN
once he was talking about how he did
acid he took a big dose acid and he's
never worried about death ever again
that it just alleviated his worry about
passing on wow this is that I felt the
same way after well doesn't matter
anymore yeah I think Deonte even more
specifically because they think you
might be the face to mine that way what
caused effect on mine that way they
don't tell it that it meant govision a
yeah visualize everything they don't
totally know they know that your brain
makes it they know that your body makes
it they should say if they know that
it's produced in your liver and their
lungs and there's some evidence now
because they found it in rats that the
pineal gland produces it which is like
that's the third eye of Eastern
mysticism that gland actually in rats
they've proven produces DMT and they
think it does so in people too you know
once I did I wanted to do it again and
again and again they say you shouldn't
do too much Mike laughing I got you know
grass what's going on here why am I
feeling this way why did this in a weird
way like humbled you I don't think you
should listen to the people say [ __ ] you
know too much I think you should do it
as much as you want that's what I agree
with - yeah if you can handle being like
Tyson you can handle doing DMT issues
thank you yeah that's what I think I'm
going that direction well I mean I mean
it's not something you do all day every
day but you can learn a lot from it it's
and it's it's very beneficial and very
strange that it's illegal you know that
it's illegal
yeah notice that McKenna had a joke
about it because your body's making it
so everybody's holding we all have it
you know it's illegal but it's like
making blooded legal everybody and then
why would he go to scenario deadly when
they find these toes yeah yeah I've
never experienced it from the toad of
only watchin television a wit would the
way they extracted grandma
squeezes pimples and busting on the
class of Maryland didn't take it off and
he later hi yeah you they let it dry in
the Sun they scrape it off with a razor
blade yeah I've only had it
synthetically made in a laboratory you
used to be able to buy it online used to
be able to buy like a [ __ ] can of it
like this big enough to get like a whole
state high she's fired online it was
totally legal incredible yeah it's weird
it's bazan it is illegal well they would
say not for human consumption
I don't know what the [ __ ] you're doing
with it if you're not using it for human
consumption but you used to be able to
buy I've never felt anything like that
before
no nothing like make me not want to do
any nothing else king of superseded that
how long ago did it happen only around
two months ago yeah did you write down
what happened after it happened or did
you record it no I wish I did
yeah we should yeah me too if you like
it goes away like a dream right and
comes off you know you're so scared you
know I love you yeah love everybody yeah
so passed out yeah did you have a hard
time letting go at the beginning else
fighting I don't think stop wanting to
stop now just jump stop the [ __ ] now
stop in the growling hey
I can't go for the ride dude it was like
oh man like I'm dying things are going
off them seen the Aztec things I've seen
taupe I'm gonna seem weird animal but
mainly it flashes it's like another
chamber its boom flashing that phone
yeah you've gone it's like the rock are
you taking off room yeah it's beyond
your imagination
yeah death is inconceivable can you
explain it to no one
well I'm hoping that they start with
psilocybin because I know maps there
they're doing some great work with that
trying to get these things legalized
especially they're doing MDMA studies
with veterans and people with PTSD and
they're having great results
they're moving in the psilocybin they
would love to get psilocybin legal and
it's up for ballot I think was in Oregon
is that where it is it's up for I think
Oregon is up for legalization this year
and it may be eventually in California
as well they made I think I'm gonna do a
session it should be legal doesn't kill
anybody it should be it's not a bad
thing if they regulate it if they make
it for therapeutic use and just set up
centers where experts can show but they
shouldn't make it prohibited for people
to own it or even grow their own it's
not a bad idea to set up places where
people can do it under a professionals
care a shamans care or physicians care
that's a good idea but making it illegal
is a bad idea because it helps a lot of
people you know people think of it as a
party drug they think you're gonna do
mushrooms and freak out and go [ __ ]
run around naked
do my since I love mushrooms yeah well
psilocybin and DMT are very closely
related chemically all those really
potent psychedelic drugs are very
closely related they all break down in
some similar paths inside your brain and
give you that that weird ego dissolving
experience that's once the drugs you do
it most some ego enhancing right like
coke yeah the baddest mother gone yeah
you know you've never had coffee I've
never had coke never never oh man yeah
that one I ducked when I was in high
school my friends cousin used to sell it
and he wasted away to nothing him and
his girlfriend would hang out in the
attic never come out they would just
sell coke and watch TV was bad like it
was like a vampire bit him and he came
up when she's getting that kind of
vicious cycle as a rat yeah yeah I saw
it I ducked it
I ducked it early never did coke man was
the first time he did coke I don't know
I was kid I haven't well [ __ ] I get
involved drug the early in life wow
that's crazy eleven twelve yeah
I was still living in Brownsville
Brooklyn I first ate cocaine wow that's
a crazy
um listen I would never let my children
have a ten-year-old daughter and eight
euros I would never let them live the
life that I live I would hate that I'll
always fight for heart never wouldn't be
an environment that I grew up in yeah of
course
well you know you have the benefit of
having gone through it you know no one
else could ever understand how how how
difficult any of your life must have
been for you it's got to be one of the
harder things when you did that
documentary it's a amazing documentary
when you're very honest you're very
honest and and you're very open about
all your experiences and the one thing I
took away after like no one can
understand you could you could hear a
guy talk like this I could hear you say
these things I could see the videos of
your fights to see the videos your
experience but to understand the life
that you lived it's impossible it's just
a guess it's like your guess for someone
like me from the outside it's just
really interesting I look I think about
this young kid from Brooklyn New York
comes to custom ro at 13 12 you know you
know something
Oh son I have a little self-esteem this
guy gives me this big [ __ ] ego you
know I mean I live but you know I live
by the rules of that ego and I stand
I've accomplished so much then a
Dominator ego yeah you're yourself
strong people yeah yeah this anybody
could be a lawyer 200 pounds I'm staring
you down this weird environment growing
up that way you know cuz we have people
we try to avoid fights you know mean
Brian for my instance we avoid fights
just to be able to see what you do a UFC
guy you're a fighter this is what you do
for a job a lifestyle that's really
bizarre you were getting positive
reinforcement from thinking like that
for my first time in your life
absolutely yeah I ever felt like that
before we liked taking up a big drug
lucious booming it felt like get him and
then everybody telling you you great
yeah you know for the first time in your
life never understood that and you know
what else
custom model used to do with me he used
to take me to a hypnotist he was a
hypnotist as well he and I used to go in
the
the hypnotist motions what kind of [ __ ]
do they make you do
you know how they do it yes you relax
you go under you totally focus on
blackness nothingness right you go under
and yes being the savage intelligent
having no animal just working you're
gonna do this you're gonna be a
ferocious animal you're gonna fight put
both hands to the body you lose your job
you do this and ferocious fashion and
they speak taller than we have I was
younger and you were like 12 13 years
old Wow so they're putting you under and
just teaching you that mindset yeah whoa
did he give you any advice on how to
shut it off no there's no time no time
I'm not gonna teach him the off switch
just hit the gas that's what it was
together asteroid these guys these guys
in our way of you know me greatness
glory it's one of the hardest things
that many fighters I've and that I've
watched over the years have the problem
of shutting it off like turning it on
and living like that and just wanted to
be a Dominator within learning how to be
a father
learning how to be man my first my first
lifetime with children and stuff trying
to do this stuff man I felt so disasters
thing it was just um I had no idea what
I was doing - I had no idea who I was
what arena I was stepping into it was
just it was just disasters I find out I
spent most of my adult life now I'm
apologizing to my kids you know I mean
yeah yeah I can imagine being fitted
horrible father
do you think they understand what the
[ __ ] that you were going through they
understand like I have no idea if I try
to basically make sure that part of my
life is empty now I live different life
for my kids Ryan family now yeah well
that's beautiful it's beautiful that you
you you like Thomas saying earlier you
have a lot of self-reflection you've
managed to look at your life and and
find out what's what has value to you
what would helps you you always have to
do self-evaluation I'm gonna strong
believer in that
you might have to check you you have to
check yourself I agree yeah well
especially a guy like you who's you know
you're you've been checked your egos
been checked your life has been checked
you've had so many down moments as well
as up moments you've had double the full
ride of experiences never thought of
surviving with my ego being chicken no
idea that wasn't what it was about so
you thought if your ego checked you
would go away I'll be nothing with my
ego Wow yeah well I mean it makes sense
when you're going through all that
hypnosis when you're 12 and 13 years old
that's a crazy thing to do to a kid
because no I did what I wanted to do it
feel bad kick feet feel bad you could
tell you know I watched a video of you
real recently you were about 16 16 17
years old and you were sparring with
some big guy who is a professional
heavyweight and you were it was what was
fascinating to me about it wasn't just
watching move around when you were young
and still learning but it was also you
were upset at yourself after it was over
you didn't think it went well
and I was like remember you don't
remember he's an interesting video man
you were like I didn't go well could
tell it didn't go well I was a thick
perfection yeah that's what I was gonna
say it seemed like it like you were
obsessed that's my whole life they
thought they would look at bachlin watch
box to read about fighters about
fighters fighters oh my god don't be a
groupie that's another amazing
imagine that you also knew Jim Jacobs
and that yeah and fight library that I
did with what films amazing this is pre
VHS right people at VHS but not many and
there's fight those fights weren't on
VHS no way remember before like if you
didn't if you missed the fight you
weren't gonna see it again right yeah
yeah and Jim Jacobs you kept those
things on like a regular old projector
type thing a myth you know listen to the
voiceover on some of those old fights
it's Jim Jake - yeah it's him doing
commentary on some of the old fights
that didn't have anybody study all these
guys all day and all night he studied oh
yeah he was through you that I learned
about a lot of fighters when you would
talk about Jack Dempsey I talk about
different fighters from the old days I
learned about a lot of those guys from
you I went back and watched some of
those tapes and now it's beautiful now
you can just get on you too
you see whatever you want everything see
all of it but to go back and that's my
way to my office and I can't wait I want
you to come by to the ranch
- and love - I'm in productive it's
gonna be off so you said 2020 - yeah so
four year or what is it yeah four years
from now three years from that'll be
pretty awesome yeah that's awesome well
the plans look amazing you know how long
you guys been working towards this Amy
listen we have seen the property and
then we purchased it and we were just um
we're just overwhelmed with this
probably I don't know maybe a year ago
maybe no maybe a maybe years so you know
or you can have a gym up there hey well
I never thought but we will have because
we have the Wellness
yeah dude how great would it be if you
taught like a boxing class Harry no no
that's stuff we gotta hang out there and
work out just a fun boxing class like
hitting the heavy bag just something you
don't have to get people beating each
other up do you know how much people
would pay to smoke weed and come where
how to box from your smoke we do you
smoke weed with people just regular
folks yeah yeah yeah I was trying to get
my wife to smoke with me now Chism's
well yeah she's my thing she can't
function during the day all right well
if you I would imagine if I was a mother
I would be very hard to get high cuz I
get paranoid you know I'd be like yeah
yeah at nighttime it's different smoke a
little weed relax how did you ever do
anything I did kickboxing and hyeondo
tournaments I was uh I was pretty good
at Taekwondo I won a bunch of state
championships and won a few few national
tournament you know you wanted to get
physical in another human being and do
this stuff you know you can't be in
right frame of mind I want to do this
stuff realize that I was not in the
right frame of mind
yeah and that's dealing with fear drives
you insane yeah deal with that drives
people insane I was insane during my
career
yes madly insane from fear yeah
obviously I never went through anything
like the level that you went through but
for these full-contact taekwondo fights
i was always scared and but i was scared
before that I was
I moved around a lot I was a little kid
I was never very big and we moved from
New Jersey to San Francisco when I was
seven from San Francisco to Florida when
I was 11 Florida to Boston when I was 14
or 13 so it's just always moving in new
schools always dealing with new kids and
I wasn't big and I didn't know how to
fight and I got picked on and I didn't
like it so I said I wanna I want to
figure out a fight and so I started
getting into martial arts and I just
became obsessed with it I did it every
day I started teaching I was teaching at
Boston University I was teaching a
Taekwondo course when I was 19 I was
competing from the time I was 15 I just
threw myself into it it's all I did
every day I worked at the school I was
there every day I had the keys I closed
up I opened up where I in because of you
because hearing about you and you you
were running in the morning when you
knew that everybody else was asleep that
gave you an edge I'd go there in the
middle of the night and open up and work
out I just wanted to just have an edge
you know and I listened to what you said
I said that's a great way to have an
edge I became obsessed with it but there
was no future in it and then what
happened was I went from Taekwondo to
kickboxing and when I started kickboxing
I started getting [ __ ] up dudes are
beating the [ __ ] out of me because I was
realized like I can't keep people at the
same distance anymore because I didn't
know how to use my hands properly like I
knew how to throw some punches a little
bit from Taekwondo but it's not nearly
sophisticated as boxing or kickboxing
and so then I started kickboxing
training and then I started realizing
like there's no future in this like what
am i doing I'm just getting my brains
beat in you know and I'm hard sparring
to the sparring was rough it was Boston
style put the gloves on beat the [ __ ]
out of each other figure it out as you
go along so a lot of headaches and you
know but it was it was hard for me to
shut that that part of me off the part
of me they just wanted to conquer the
part of me just wanted to win all the
time to figure out a way to be more
intense more driven more focused but
when I did stop fighting it was a huge
relief
like the relief part was worth the the
extra anxiety that I got it was worth it
just for the relief of not not thinking
about fighting all the time not thinking
about when's the next tournament when's
the next event when's the next thing I'm
doing it was just that
wait well for you it had to be wait
crazy because the money's at the wait
it's the heavyweight championship of the
world
I always wanted to make my mentor happy
yeah that's my goal to make him happy
when he died was it weird not having a
person like mine it was so man it was
just um emptiness it was just and then
people who we thought with our friends
than that we say we're gonna be good to
they have started when he died they had
started going in for the kill you just
wanna you ask me for means what seemed
like you and Kevin Rooney had a good
combination at the beginning when he
died when when come we didn't know what
we were gonna do they were thinking
about getting rid of Kevin a son I was
saying I don't wanna be nobody else
right anybody was comfortable with Kevin
in the style of the way we were gonna
any one of you know let's just keep
Kevin yeah and Kevin was a great trainer
for me very well-respected trainer yeah
it was a good relationship but the way
it worked in the beginning and looked
like but then like all things you know
Kevin used to train me and then fight
now finally than the caught no really
yeah Wow Wow and this was all what was
he training you before before cus tight
as well well yeah how many how many
years before costs died was he like
holding mitts for you and if the couple
but he knew you well yes
did you watch our well did he watch
fights with you as well did you what
were you watching those funny noises
know what to fight think once we um
started training with each other we
started watching fights together because
your stuff that was the other thing to
your style the way you would come out
was so reminiscent of old fighters when
you come out with no socks on black
shoes wow that would think my mind I'm
thinking about gladiator me - I would
another thing I look at enough looking
at stuff were you were tough man I know
what you're saying I know what you're
saying but you were when you fought
Marvis Frazier on was that ABC war yeah
little thing maybe she had fight
I remember watching that fight going
holy [ __ ] holy SH that was like being
locked into a ring with a tornado that
was wild a yeah it was the tough
that was your peak that was when it was
peak scary
you know you were coming up and
everybody was just terrified it's just a
wild thing to watch man to be a part of
it to be you yeah I wanted to make my
mentor real happy though that's my main
goal and fighting
it's a powerful goal yeah did you ever
try to go back and get hypnotized after
all that's over to try to maybe calm
down that part of your mind
the no um I never did I had told I think
help me out the total yeah stuff that
stuff will help me out yeah did we'd
help you out at all and pretty much yeah
I mean but I have to do it every day I'd
do it all the time
right dude all the time then yeah if I
went to another country and I didn't
have my weed I'll be insane what a
couple of days a month yeah yeah the
rest the world will catch up eventually
they'll catch up eventually it slowly
happened and we were talking about it
before the show started that just a few
years ago if you smoked weed you you
felt like you were a criminal like you
have to hide though they look around man
you look around that a cop still like
that in New York I was in New York
recently we had a hide we'd still
illegal there I'm like how is this New
York City so antiquated today so stupid
just doesn't make any sense
especially when like we're both high
right now then man the kite it's fine
everything's good having a nice
conversation totally agree
how many fights did Jim Jacobs have in
that library I don't know thousands of
me I watched thousand guys fighting in
1898 watch them all Wow
who-who were standouts for you outside
of the standard like obviously Jack
Johnson yeah he was awesome too um he
was just amazing he was ahead of his
time fighting little guys like Tony
Kevin Airy handy Armstrong Barney Ross
guys like that
Benny Leonard this guys are just they
evolved buckling to the level where I
can evolve to now they became they were
superstars in that time who's that crazy
middleweight who went up to fight Jack
Johnson yes Stanley Ketchel
that's right he's a bad head punch yeah
he the badass then he got killed
yeah guys I'm yes
so this guy's good yeah he was a tough
girl what are you gonna do about it beat
the guy he'll be disrespecting the guy
and the guy came back and shot him yeah
Stanley kid threw the real wild and
crazy guy well most of the greats were
yeah wow that's a good feeling for
anyone well when you talk about like
your life and like the way you were
living if you go back to most the greats
like Roberto Duran he was a mother
father's mom he's beautiful it was
beautiful rhythm with it yeah
there's so many of the greats were just
wild wild people you know I think that
that fear that breathed that out of you
yeah but then there was some greats that
were just real disciplined like
struggling in Marvin Hagler's my best
example for that when I was a kid
growing up in Boston Hagler was the
middleweight champion the world and I
used to see they stop video him running
they played it on the news he was
running on the there was the dunes sand
dunes and Cape Cod in the winter
freezing cold with a hoodie on running
screaming war whoa it was amazing Marvin
Hagler made you want to just get out of
your house and go running in the snow
you know he was so disciplined that was
the thing that I always got out of
watching him wasn't that he was so wild
he was so mentally strong he had an iron
chin and his discipline was impeccable
his D was just constantly training never
out of shape never got fat always doing
sit-ups and push-ups him ferocious
animal right through the body yeah oh he
was chiseled he was a machine that fight
with Tommy Hearns
one of the greatest middleweight
encounters of a long time chaos
I mean it's we didn't know what was that
we thought I stopped the fight I thought
the fightin the Tommy hands it'll be the
winner is skillful as they were they
decided to just smash just get into the
setter and [ __ ] fight there was no
like Tommy Hearns could try to try to
use his jab you know try to take him out
you know Sugar Ray Leonard did their own
that they weren't at their prime then
yeah you know I wanted to see those two
guys and their primers go at it yeah
Sugar Ray Leonard went especially when
he fought Hagler he fought higher smart
to stay the [ __ ] away exactly I heard
the craziest rumor tell me if this is
the craziest rumor that Marvin
Aguilar like decided to bet on himself
for that fight didn't knew that he was
going to lose like they had it set up
and then retired and went to Italy as a
ridiculous rumor right I don't know what
anybody did but I never heard anything
like that he never heard that one no but
he's the more one of the most
interesting end of careers ever heard
I'm rumored that he didn't fight the
fight that he should have fight that he
should have fought right you know I mean
well the rumor was he went to Italy
because the mob said everything yeah
some thing he went to Italy and became a
giant movie star but he's the only guy
that I can think of in recent memory
that literally went out on top had is
unbelievably close fight with Sugar Ray
Leonard a lot of people think he could
have won that fight very close decision
and then says that's it see ya I'm done
everybody comes back come back you know
I guess I'm at one time that's your
whole life I won't think of I'm
surprised I never came back that was
just my whole life that's my whole
identity yeah yeah I mean um but when
you did retire and when you retired in
the ring that was the most honest
retirement speech I've ever heard a
boxer give ever he's just like I don't I
don't have this in me anyone swim in the
air anymore just um that was pretty
bizarre for myself you know this is what
I base my life on doing I when I first
started doing that I'm I dedicate my
life to this stuff he has to see that
it's not even no longer happened was
pretty weird when did you know that you
didn't want to do it anymore
I'm knowing years before that bite was
still being very successful yeah like
when like what year like do you remember
around when you start thinking it I
remember probably around what the 2000
area so by the time that that's post
Holyfield
yeah after yeah and you just get it done
too much I was just one of them running
beating guys you know guys get hit
something from gotta be so scared
yeah what did what did you have in mind
like that's the hardest thing right to
swing from that to the next thing like
how do you take how do you take this
crazy exciting life oh no I fed
everything let me if get high for a
while
and figure this out that was the plan
yeah any party for a while I figured
this stuff out what did you figure out
that I wanted to do with things so I
started my wife arranged for me to be
this death being on stage that she
created the Maya yeah that's a brilliant
idea
cuz you're also the first fighter that
ever did that because many fighters have
great stories but very few of them ever
I don't think anybody besides you was
ever put into it we were all just see if
he did it man it's just amazing we did a
monocle we didn't own we didn't believe
that people want to see this though well
like I said the documentary was amazing
so people want to hear the live version
of you talking about it and to see you
live in person because the first time we
did it the first thing we did on
Broadway that is really that's sure
about how it's going to turn out so we
invited all of our friends we had taken
they gave all our friends and people we
love like names report them to the show
and so when we started they started
laughing but I left I ran to my right
wife around let's do this baby what's
going on listening okay you know I
didn't want this show to be a comedy
turned out to be a hard gritty show
about a tough guy I made it to his
toughness and he just came up with me
talk about myself how much the schmuck I
am you know he loved it I think that was
part of it is because like they all
everybody knew you were this tough guy
but they didn't know that you could be
so self-deprecating and have so much fun
with it all you know that's what people
loved it because yeah obviously they're
doing a writing from a moving scene
who's playing you in a movie
Jamie Jamie Foxx he could do it he could
do anything he could do anything
anything that guy could be the [ __ ]
president United States he could be a
pilot that goes to the moon he could do
whatever the [ __ ] you want him to do it
yeah he could do whatever he wants he'll
probably bulk up like crazy to do it
absolutely really Wow
yeah Jamie could pull it off
Michael Jai White pulled it off huh
Michael John why didn't do it like Gino
I've done it into a bag laughing what he
did I think he did a good job he I loved
him and spawned he's a great guy
do you know him well no he's a great guy
great guy very smart guy very humble guy
really really intelligent and a great
martial artist too
Michael Jai White there's a kill Kishen
karate black belt is badly my fight do
you fight in the UFC no when he was
fighting there was no UFC around but he
did a lot of karate tournaments and
stuff it's very good I watched him train
before he's legit very legit like I said
real real good guy but yeah I agree
Jamie Foxx man Jamie Foxx is on another
planet he's just got this level of
competence and skill and artistry in his
singing and his comedy and his acting he
could do anything he could play you he's
gonna hang out with you for a while I
don't know what he's gotta he's got to
hang out with you pretty awesome he's
got to hang out with you gotta absorb it
right yeah are you gonna be there kiss
consultant are you gonna be like [ __ ] I
wouldn't never said that I would like to
say that yeah but for some reason they
just um they have the Hollywood ways of
doing things
yeah I mean then we can come out
hollywood ish yeah because some things
they're just really wild they try to
switch it to appear presentable right
yeah they try to change the story and no
one else I realized who when Hollywood
perspective something that really just
is just still unbelievable yeah
unbelievable
yeah well do you know that movie
Foxcatcher did you know that yeah the
roughly movie mm-hmm I remember that
story of the young guy remember that
yeah that Mark Schultz is Dave Schultz
at Marlys Dave Schultz is the one who
got murdered Mark Schultz is the guy who
fought in the UFC here's what's crazy
about that movie I don't know how much
of that movies accurate I don't know I
wasn't there but what I do know is the
one thing that I for sure know happened
they changed when he fought in the UFC
Mark only fought the UFC once he fought
a guy named Big Daddy Goodrich Gary Big
Daddy
yeah big black I wore karate ghee and
then eventually got really key later in
his career but he's a legend Big Daddies
imagining them in the movie it's not Big
Daddy and the movies fighting some white
guy it doesn't make any sense yeah they
just take changed who he's fighting for
no restore achill event it's like if you
for whatever reason they decided not
have you fight Trevor Berbick you fought
someone else like you fought Gerry
Cooney for the title which I'm gonna be
great they'd be like why would you
change history like I hope they don't do
that I'm not going to one i can't one do
they do something like that have to be
they did it with the UFC they did it
with locks can be right but it doesn't
make it any better that's what's crazy
it doesn't make the movie any better to
have him fight a Russian guy doesn't
make me verify known right especially
for people like me that are in the
audience that go oh look look who's
playing Big Daddy how did he do a Big
Daddy Big Daddy stuff he took Big Daddy
down it yeah they did whatever you
wanted to him he's Mark Schultz he was a
[ __ ] of a wrestler I mean him
and his brother were savages there were
savages they were just made out of world
the deal with that guy had they hooked
up with that guy was really really rich
and there's no money in amateur
wrestling and these guys a lot of them
are really struggling when they're
trying to make the Olympics team I mean
they're getting by barely they barely
have enough money for healthy food and
they need sponsors and sometimes to get
sponsors like a rich guy who owns a
business you know he loves the Olympics
he loves wrestling maybe he wrestled in
college and he'll take care of them get
maybe get him some vitamins maybe
sponsor him with the and then you know
they have various people that help them
with their training and their food but
this guy came along and said look I'm
gonna build a gigantic facility to
create the best wrestling program and
pay you guys all money to come and train
here and they couldn't help it
it's like they were poor they didn't
know what to do I understand that yeah
and he was a guy who was like a trust
fund guy got all his money from his
family and he was just some crazy rich
[ __ ] and he wound up shooting one of
them yeah I mean that's what it is I
mean the still lucky said the story
itself he's [ __ ] crazy enough the
actual story they didn't have to change
anything of it so I know they changed
that part of it so who knows what else
in the movie they added or changed or
[ __ ] with they [ __ ] with something
they didn't have to [ __ ] with they were
in Hollywood with it
the way that they didn't have to do so
it makes you you question all the other
things that happened in the movie that's
pretty bizarre so for you they can't do
that your life is crazy insane I'm know
what I was saying about the car we don't
really want to do this stuff man I
really want to go on the screen with my
life and be severe with these people
yeah I don't really need that I think
about this and this cam has been ready
to pop off and do really well I'm
thinking really that we need this money
you said I hurt you it's not gonna hurt
you it's gonna help you anything helps
you at this point you're so honest that
anything that you've done in the past
that you're embarrassed about or you
shameful of it just makes it's just
better this is better for you it's like
yeah you made mistakes is people can
learn from them these are beneficial so
watching someone like you talk about
your life is beneficial for people
because you learn how you can overcome
these experiences how how bad things can
be for you you learn how bad you can
[ __ ] up and people need to see [ __ ] like
that it's good for it's good for
civilizations good for our culture I
think so a plus a guy like you who was
like I said when I was a kid you were
the [ __ ] man I mean you were the
[ __ ] man
to have a guy like you be
self-deprecating explaining and laughing
about things it makes it even if it
sinks in more it's like you were saying
what we were saying about cus D'Amato
that his wisdom is sunk in like he was
the the gravel and his voice and the
intensity in his eyes and the wisdom and
his words it sunk in I remembered his
quotes for years afterwards because he
lives so much because he had so much and
that's the same thing with you man when
you when you're talking about your life
experiences like people listen they take
it in because they know you lived an
extraordinary life so they better not
[ __ ] this movie up yeah really extreme
extreme as it gets
what's Mark's dream other than soldier
those are the only people that live a
more extreme life first responder
soldiers firemen police officers yeah
that's it I mean they they're seeing
death and violence every day other than
them you probably live the most extreme
life ever
who the [ __ ] could relate to you do you
ever get together with
they're like world-class Pro boxers sort
of no but the guy that do get him into
the guy you talk about the veteran of
this yeah
maybe tell me with the hall man yeah I
talked to seals about their time
deployed surprised they don't think
themselves out of those guys mm-hmm yeah
yeah doc thanks well a lot of those guys
are finding some relief in the same
things you've known relief and they find
relief in DMT and other psychedelics
mushrooms I think that could be a great
benefit to a lot of our veterans I
believe that 100% so I don't know why
they don't want to dabble in this stuff
yeah what do you think would have
happened to you if you got a hold that
stuff while you and your prime I don't
know I don't think maybe I want to be a
fighter in yeah maybe I won't want to be
a fighter damn deep DMT might have
derailed it yeah I might want to love
everybody ever make you feel like we
come out of these I love you yeah yeah
well my hope is that with great
organizations like maps that one day
people will be able to see things like
everybody be able to see things the way
you do and then we'll all have this
understanding what these things are
they're they're tools that can help us
all these things including marijuana
it's a tool to help us you could use it
as any tool you could abuse any tool
there is you can take a hammer and hit
yourself in the head if you're stupid
you could use anything but you could
also use it you know and make builders
have a beautiful house and with cannabis
you can you could use it to make even
makes you a nicer person it does makes
you more I feel more vulnerable I have
more of a sense of community I'm always
hugging people when I'm high I want to
hug everybody you know I agree it's a
better feeling there yeah I mean it
makes you it makes you feel kind agree I
like feeling high what does it like for
you to watch boxing these days it's not
my life anymore do you don't watch it at
all it did you watch Tyson Fury Wilder
great fight I was in the air flying when
they were fight oh really did you didn't
watching the highlights or anything for
some of the highlights yeah how crazy is
Deontay Wilder power good stuff crazy
rights because he's built so strange
totally incredible with faith and chill
incredible incredible and gets up and
wins the rest of the round that's what's
really incredible it's amazing amazing
file yeah so you don't follow you know
following okay um you know I'm that part
of my life um I'm all right
I got mixed feelings to that part of my
life right that's tough but I don't like
about myself and stuff is right I try to
forget that stuff I'm on a whole
different fight and yeah so even
watching other people bar you Don only
what's nothing I try to stay away what's
possible so watching other people Vox
makes you think about yourself when you
were fighting it reminds you of it kind
of yeah yeah oh we've got so much Nathan
and I was the cool guys yeah right
like who out yeah there's no one out
there today that's got that mean vicious
persona guys yeah you when you were in
the ring doing a post-fight interview
saying you wanted to eat your children
you want to eat someone's children I'm
never saying this is the craziest
[ __ ] post-fight interview was about
Lennox Lewis right yeah the great it was
amazing it was amazing for the story for
the time I mean look what it was was
when we saw Rocky three right and mr. t
was challenging you know rocky and he
would say all that crazy [ __ ] about what
he was gonna do my prediction beautiful
what you did is you took that just
cranked it up to 11 and threw gasoline
on it lit it on fire you just took that
kind of ferocious [ __ ] talk yeah I look
at some of those a long time saying yeah
anyway it's a different world now my
world feel different now
do you feel when you watch that stuff
that you feel almost like trapped by
that past like that you have to
acknowledge and you don't even
acknowledge it anymore yeah I'm almost a
little bit like I don't want to be
involved wish that never happens yeah
yeah but kind of had to happen for you
to be who you I know it's because people
are this is the real reason right people
still people love that guy yeah yeah and
people love that I didn't like that guy
that much so I have my conflicting with
people that like that guy me
living my life that I am living now yeah
well people loved that guy because that
guy gave them a drug and that drug was
excitement like you you turn on the TV I
go [ __ ] here we go Michael spanks Mike
Tyson here we go and boom oh that's what
people wanted they wanted that
excitement they knew some crazy [ __ ] was
about to go down
unpredictable you can't you don't no one
knows what's gonna happen in a fight
it's gonna be a right or a left is he
gonna move right he's gonna move left
how's it gonna work out you don't know
how long could Spinks last you don't
know and everybody was excited and that
was that's what you brought people you
brought people this this chaotic moment
you slap down the money in the
pay-per-view got at your popcorn and you
waited for the rush the rush of
excitement of the crazy days crazy days
I hate to keep bringing your head back
to that but just for me as a kid growing
up during that time it was a big part of
my you know my becoming an adult
it was during your era your era of
dominance I would look at my kids and I
think why these guys are pretty much
middle class kids they live their life
to do what they wanted to go to college
everything I whatever I would never want
to put that pressure on my son that you
have to be the total best you have to
dominate everybody you gonna be the best
that ever liveth this is put that kind
of pressure
that's incredible would never do that to
though yeah it would never work probably
I mean I don't think a kid that grows up
in a loving household would support it
yeah that's boxing for when you have
nothing yeah we need to boxing when you
have nothing because that's a lot of
that's a lot of dedication that's a lot
of pain there's a lot of aggravation you
know really if discovering who you are
but you must be able to take pride in
the fact that your children don't ever
have to do that oh and that's why I took
the punches for they wouldn't have to do
yeah I had my firm I have the son of 16
he wanted to be a boxer
you're being tripped into your trips and
also vacation you ever fight again I
don't know buddy
maybe I do fight some guy like me
Manimal get on my kids go through that
crap that's the degrading some guy like
that beam on you yeah that's the thing
is the fuel that you had the the the
burning inferno inside you you can't
replicate God you don't understand that
they don't I don't know you know a lot
of stuff from inspiring inspires a lot
of success yeah you know yeah they don't
have to deal with that kind of shame
right right
shame pain exactly feeling being left
out feeling of not belonging and you
know I do this I'm gonna be a buddies I
love me yeah crazy feeling it's really
amazing to get people look you wanna be
accepted so badly yeah imagine that it's
really accepted keep it a look at you
you know I know what kind of minefield
that left they either won't people just
look at you yeah oh man yeah but it's
beautiful that you could describe it
that way now like you've stepped outside
of it long enough do you recognize what
it was when it was over coming however
think I think he's thirty that man of
the greater this guy was a god Wow I
want to be like that you know this is
crazy this is crazy that you can inspire
the belief that you're more than what
you are
well it was also those feelings of
conquering we're giving you the first
success and good feelings of your life
and the fact that they programmed you I
mean that's something that I don't think
a lot of people are aware of the the
hypnotism the hypnotism and the the
putting those thoughts into your mind
which were hugely beneficial you could
tap into that mind zone right before you
competed they mean they they gave you a
clear path they give you a clear path to
use your fury with this like very
analytical approach with perfect boxing
technique and an amazing mentor with
incredible
knowledge and they just let you loose
yep do the after yeah with the other
than do the athlete yeah bad intention
yeah being bad intention and have
enthusiasm when you're fighting and love
every minute of it yeah
look at you getting fired up again yeah
do you work out anymore
no I Mack you away from that stuff you
don't even like all that stuff you know
spin class right no less stuff from
reactivate to my ego oh really yeah oh
wow I'm gonna get ripped off they react
that's the thing about like extreme
winners extreme winners that ego is hard
in fact my ego i'ma lose like I'm losing
candidate I lose everything
what if you like go jogging can you go
jogging no I do my treadmill working
Stoke a treadmill that's it but if I
thought the thing that I'm special if I
get a glance a glimmer of that thing for
me whoa yeah do you better than know I
saw a video you hit in the bag recently
was a couple years ago mm-hmm you still
hit the bag still throw some bombs
I do partly for the camera yeah that's
what you're doing but I'm like damn you
could still move you still have it in
you right
I don't know when it's in your body half
it being to do this it feel weird but I
was gonna get to when if you were
standing front that heavy bag and you
start rattling off combinations and
people you start thinking like oh [ __ ]
I'm actually Mike Tyson like I was that
guy I am that guy who went through that
I am the youngest heavyweight champion
of all time I am that guy to destroy
Tyrell Biggs I am that guy that knocked
out Larry Holmes I'm that guy okay my
guy I look at that guy for money if
giving me a platform to help me forget
about that guy Wow yeah it's it's
beautiful that you have that that
mindset it is because most people who've
accomplished as much as you have they
don't want to ever let the past oh [ __ ]
let that go the thing go but do you know
do you recognize that that's a beautiful
part of your personality you had one of
the most successful boxing careers ever
but you don't want to you know
nothing to do with it you don't want to
we want to acknowledge it exist you wish
it went away in order to arrive to that
next chapter in life you have to forget
chapter they came before you
yeah and focus on the chapter ahead of
you yes yes
that's a great lesson and from coming
from you that lesson I think is gonna
hit home with a lot of people King fell
yes honey 100 percent because you
accomplished so much because you were
the youngest heavyweight champion of all
time because you're the baddest man on
the planet this big hero for a lot of
people like me when I was growing up to
see you now say that's then I'm done no
nothing I don't watch it I don't work
out it I'm not I'm not even a part of
that anymore I'm concentrating my life
right now and I'm happy and I love
people you know Joe that's really crazy
but when you think about this listen you
know being that person that guy that
sent me the psych ward a couple of times
it family took so many other places the
prison is let me play through that guy's
a trip yeah I had you in the underwear
holding a tiger chance a trip man what
did you go to the psych ward for it's
been crazy violent probably felt about
hurting myself or something crazy like
that what do they do when they take you
in the psych ward how do they treat you
oh no same way everybody this is Mike
you know but I mean how do they take
care of you what do they do for you I
mean how do they take my [ __ ] pills
those things are something yeah
throwing you out because I'll be doing a
zombie swag event yeah yeah that is what
they do huh
yeah just call me down medically
pharmaceutically well you know what's
going on we can't react to it change
this and then once they got you calmed
down enough to go alright you can go I
don't know I don't think time for me to
go I had to go what is a day in the life
of Mike Tyson like now look what it was
a typical day get up in the morning I go
to my office my cannabis office we do
deals and we get investments and I come
home at five o'clock and I go see my
kids left at the office later and I come
home
I'm away from my kids if really bizarre
like we see a Newport Beach now that's
not really um very now he's very upscale
but it's very quiet yeah not like Las
Vegas at all no one my daughter plays
tennis up there so we pretty much um
situated up there's not like I said baby
can we move to Hollywood you know he has
no clue Tennis Hall of a tennis
requirement for here in Newport Beach so
we stay here Newport is nice though it's
a good place it's near the oceans got
clean it's just different for me I bet
yeah did you like living in Vegas though
because always craziness and the fight
did bring great parties do you go we had
some great parties so you've settled
into this business life it seems like
pretty easily like you you seem to be
enjoying yourself
hey founder I want to do and if fresh
start
no I mean yeah doing a total you know me
my main objective and anything I've been
walking on and being am and father
myself what it's all been because of a
fresh start I feel fresh it feels newer
man could stopping that could be in my
way and it's just awesome feeling so
this is from doing that one DMT
experience you sent you into it one time
but I didn't mean a many times that you
know but yeah this really um I don't
know what it is I'm trying to figure it
out but I've changed but you don't
figure it out let's don't know how yeah
um I describe it for a lot of people
it's like resetting a computer you reset
a computer out of fresh new desktop and
there's only one folder on the desktop
and that folder says my old [ __ ]
this is listen stop I'm saying to myself
right now
sometimes I'm wondering this new feeling
I'm possessing right now if it I'm a
real feeling this stuff really help i am
i lying to myself again till the next
moment that next feeling come to do some
drugs but to be with somebody else
what's really going on that feeling
gonna come back yeah this moments that
feel feel like I'm never coming back it
can never come back if you decide that
it's never coming back but you have to
make that decision pretty much every day
but you can you can never come back if
you want or you could slip into the old
ways that's what
a lot of people do one of the when a lot
of people fall into drug addictions
relapsing when they relapse they're not
physically addicted when they're
relapsed obviously they're clean and
then they decide to go back in it's
because there's comfort in those old
patterns because this new way of life is
just they get anxiety they feel like
it's a lot of pressure to stay clean
let's explain it I hate that I always
hated that all the way I never wanted to
do it but then I do them again and never
one that I hate no no I want you good
things going on yeah doc dog vicious
cycle it's real dark yeah
it's self destruct dog yeah what about
ego inflating and self-deprecating of
the stroke it also alleviates you from
the responsibility of improving 100%
that pressure of like keeping it
together staying sober you know being
disciplined all that stuff once it's
gone it's gone like I'm just [ __ ]
crazy I'm crazy this is just what I do
I'm crazy and it's easy to fall into
that trap and that's what happens to a
lot of people who relapse with drugs I
never want to go back to that again it's
just a no-win situation that's one of
the great things about marijuana that
people don't understand they think that
a drug is a drug as a drug they're all
falling under the same category but you
can use marijuana and just be peaceful
and not chaotic and the opposite will
make you think more about the
consequences of ruining your life okay
they sound ridiculous I got I got a foot
in with the treatment she came one time
for Andrew Golota I got um I had tested
I tested for marijuana and they charged
me $300,000 Jesus Christ
finally $200,000 that's a lot of my
where that money go who did it the
Commission did that's what they did
yeah that's crazy $300,000 for some weed
in your system now you're selling it
legally yeah I mean situation I'm just
going with this bizarre world and see
what happens
it's beautiful man never thought you
could do this sell marijuana no thought
being that business I know at this stage
of my life when it came at the right
particular time I saw it online I saw
Tyson ranch online I saw something on
the Instagram or something and I was
like that makes sense yeah yeah why not
man in this day and we look everybody
loves you why not why not go into
business you never dreamt it but it's
just a no-brainer
people gonna want to buy your weed just
because they love you I wanted to
distribute all over the world too that's
where it gets sketchy yeah there's spots
in Asia you don't want to bring weed to
know Singapore you can get killed
oh yeah Noma that's that some parts of
the world that they take yeah like I
went to Europe to buy weed before I mean
and it was um they were selling the
plant they weren't selling the but they
were selling the plant you had to buy
the plant went to the plant develop and
make but no it's the Wow
selling the plants that purpose they
wanted you to grow your own yeah does
the only way so you were working with a
bunch of different growers explain how
you guys are setting it up the whole
thing we working with as a growth but my
main objective is to be distributed all
over the country so - and also the ranch
where you have like a destination that
would be a resort in there and that's
where people come a little bit will be
like what's that big concert thank you
have my own concert series chinchilla
with Naima coach our Charlie
yeah that effect yeah oh that's awesome
so you're gonna do shows down there -
absolutely yeah well do them again we
got a first show when Miguel's will be
our first show in February oh wow oh
that's amazing that's beautiful but
listen man I'm very happy for you I'm
happy I'm happy to see this I'm happy to
see this transition in you I'm happy to
hear about your experiences and good
luck man
I need to come back because I'm gonna be
presenting at the UM the podcast award
Oh
yeah that's coming up soon this yeah
you'll be there no I'm gonna what is
that beef they haven't made that tell me
yeah they think do you know what that is
Gerry somebody sent it to me I'm busy
that man unfortunately yeah so you have
a podcast to tell people about that yes
because a hot boxing hot boxing yeah get
it yeah big hotbox we'd get it
boxing exactly yeah and we smoke on like
my show we having a good time yeah and
you were you had Dale Earnhardt jr. on
yeah he's our awesome guy he's a great
guy did you get high with him
no no I don't believe I did no no I
don't think it does either but uh you
think the clean-cut guy a super nice guy
almost too nice like are you real father
the tough guy
yeah his father was a savage yeah yeah
so tell people Tyson branch tell people
how they can find more information well
you have to look up time fear and just
it's is it Tyson ranch calm okay Tyson
ranch calm and you don't [ __ ] with any
social media huh I have people do that
but they tell take picture this guy for
you get third greatest something getting
friends it is ridiculous ranch official
honestly I'm on the book magazine there
you go damn we'll listen brother thank
you very much for being here man I
really appreciate it I wanted to kind of
show so much do it again
we'll do it again and let me know when
everything opens up we'll be happy to
promote it for you to let everybody know
and anytime you got something coming on
you want people to know about it let me
know thank you very much thank you
appreciate it brother
thank you very much Mike Tyson
[ __ ] all day
as cool
[Music]